[Music]
may I have your attention please we
received some extremely sad news from
the Evergreen County Sheriff
Bryce Walker was found and has been
confirmed dead it's an Irish to find the
person who killed my son we are working
every angle and we will find out what
happened someone might not could have
done this that's crazy
is it Bryce Walker did her love pink one
he hurt the most was Jessica Davis
somebody shot right Tyler has a gun
why'd you tell me I swear nothing you
don't know everything
okay clay you hated Bryce I didn't want
him dead
I know Bryce hurt you did you know
anything I found this I didn't do
anything but the police think that you
did not you need cover I got you here
were you that night Tony can you tell
for every minute if you're trying to
clear your name you need to look a
little closer to home
[Music]
I know should have said something
earlier
but I have to now
this whole [ __ ] world is better
without a minute what did you do
[Music]
[Music]